[Music]
[Applause]
hello internet
how are you good morning good afternoon
good evening wherever you are on the
planet
i'm chase jarvis i want to welcome you
to another episode of chase jarvis live
show here on
creative live if you're new to the show
this is where i sit down with the
world's top
creators entrepreneurs and thought
leaders and do everything and i mean
everything i can
to bring you what's in their brain to
help you achieve your goals and career
in hobby and in life and my guest today
i know you're here for him and not for
me
it's rich roll but before we get into it
i have to let you know a couple of the
my favorite things about him um he was
named one of the 25 fittest men in the
world and we were just joking how he
doesn't seem that fit right now
and this guy on his worst day is fitter
than i've ever been in my life
one of the 25 fittest men in the world
by men's fitness
outside magazine called him the guru of
reinvention
and i like to think of him as my friend
an endurance athlete
a wellness advocate a best-selling
author a husband a father and a dear
friend
uh he has done so much
for uh the internet done so much for the
people who follow and pay attention to
the work that he does
through sharing stories of inspiration
addiction
uh redemption and peak health uh one of
my favorite reads is his number one new
york times best-selling author or
best-selling book
finding ultra i've got the cookbook that
he put out called plant power
i'm sitting here eating a plant-powered
breakfast uh largely inspired by him
and we're here to share his new book
voicing change which i can't wait to get
into it so uh please wherever you are in
the world
tap your desk raise the roof uh
bang a pot outside and welcome mr rich
roll to the show rich
thank you so much for being here bud so
happy to be here man thank you so much
for having me it's a it's a
delight to see your your bright and
shiny face i just wish we could be
in the same room but alas that will have
to wait
alas we are uh 150 miles apart right now
i think you're in los angeles if i'm not
mistaken and i'm up here in
a crisp uh 37 degrees seattle this
morning thanks for being on the show man
it's been a long time you look
great coveted is treating you well and
uh
it looks and congrats on the new book
thanks man appreciate it got my
my covet beard rockin i got my covered
hair i don't quite have the covered
beard but
this is like my hair's been since i was
like 20. i've got the white coming in
rapidly here showing my age but uh you
know we're all doing what we can
and if it makes you feel any better it
was freezing here last night we were
down into
the high 30s as well so i feel you
los angeles um man
there is a lot of ground i want to cover
and every time we
have the good fortune of speaking
together
i get so much feedback about the
inspiration
that your story is uh we talked
uh two shows even though i think is the
third time or maybe the second time on
my show and i've been on your show
in the interim there but we've had three
substantial conversations
and the first one basically broke my
inbox
uh because your willingness to share
your own personal journey um if we can
start there just to recap in case people
are new to that uh i know we're also
broadcasting if i can for a second
we're doing the show live across uh
youtube instagram
live facebook live uh
i don't know all of the lives and
specifically at creativelive.comtv and
if you are watching right now
and you have questions for rich i'm
happy to share them with him i see those
questions whatever platform you put them
in
and i will try and uh surface the most
popular ones or the ones that strike a
chord with me here i think will strike a
chord with you rich so
uh let them rip y'all out there on the
internet
and again i think i get the questions at
creativelive.comtv
i get those first but i will see your
questions on whatever platform so
that being said take me back to rich
roll
trying to do what everybody else wanted
to do as a lawyer an entertainment
lawyer
in in los angeles some time ago start me
there and then how in the hell did you
end up here
yeah uh i don't know i asked my myself
that question
every day it's uh uh it's been a journey
but yeah i mean i would say mid-30s
i found myself as a practicing corporate
attorney
and i was always somebody who uh was
always good at following directions
but i think probably fair to say a
little bit disconnected from
my higher self i was somebody who
put education first i was an athlete in
college but
you know grades and studying were always
super important to me and from a very
early age
i worked overtime to kind of meet
parental and social expectations and
you know do kind of what we're told to
do as young people like
study hard get into the good colleges
you know get into the grad school climb
the corporate ladder
and i was successful in in doing all of
those things but
as i neared my 40s i started to have
a bit of an existential crisis about
these choices that i'd made because i
was so unfulfilled professionally
part of my story is also one of of
alcohol addiction i ended up getting
sober at 31
and that was my first introduction to
kind of some spiritual principles to
help guide my life
but it's been a long journey in trying
to implement many of those
you know into how i think about and and
you know practice the art of living
um but during this period of time um
i very much put a lot of my alcoholic
energy
into into my career i was very much a
workaholic
and i was unaware until many years later
just how much i was medicating myself
through
food and so by the time i was 39 i was
50 pounds overweight
kind of this classic couch potato you
know on a crash course with
chronic lifestyle illness uh lazy even
though i've been an athlete in college i
really wasn't looking after myself
physically
and had a a kind of health scare that
collided with this existential crisis
right before i turned 40
where i realized you know the way i was
living was no longer tenable
and i really needed to
return to first principles and do some
deep diving into myself to figure out
you know what possibly could make me
happy
and in my particular case that journey
began
with reconfiguring my relationship to my
body
and to food and has led me down you know
what i would characterize as a more
spiritual path of interconnectedness
that over many years has culminated in
the opportunity to you know sit here and
talk to you
um it happened very slowly it was like a
a glacier you know melting very
gradually
um it wasn't the result of of me you
know
breaking out on whiteboard and and
creating a vision for myself as much as
it was
about trying to reconnect with my
intuition and learning how to trust that
intuition
and having the courage in the faith to
um you know break ranks with what i was
comfortable with
and start to you know embrace uh a more
creative way of living and pursuing a
career
well to say that the internet is
inspired by you
that i myself am inspired by you would
be an understatement just to let you
know people tuning in from india from
houston from new york
from argentina
from is that japan from wow
from europe we got a paris in the house
of london romania
um so people are here for you
and the story that you just shared
especially about overcoming addiction is
is also clearly resonating
uh john nelser says rare rich's journey
with alcohol helped
inspire him to give it up the age of 32.
it's said that it's said that um
alcoholism is a symptom
it's not the disease itself and any
addiction and
when you said you were medicating
yourself do you know
why was this childhood trauma was it the
fact that you weren't living your
highest self
in what way were you disconnected as you
said from your
your true self and you know how did you
if again indeed you believe that was the
the um
motivation for for your addiction
uh and and how did you come to
understand
what that gap was the gap that was
making you so
uh hurt that turned you to uh to to
alcohol
yeah the question why is a kind of a
mystery box
one of the things that i've kind of
learned over the years is to not
indulge myself too deeply in pursuing
the why
i try to focus on the solution for today
because i think the why although
informative
doesn't really help me figure out how to
move forward on a moment-to-moment basis
but to answer the question
i think you know childhood trauma is
certainly an aspect of it
you know if you ask people in in in the
12-step community
you know they'll just say well you're an
alcoholic because you're an alcoholic
maybe it's genetic maybe it's childhood
trauma maybe it's some combination of
both i'm sure that's the case
with me um and i've done a lot of
interpersonal work to kind of untangle
those knots and and heal some of that
childhood trauma but i do you know
recall very vividly that as a young
person
i was just one of those kids who felt
like everybody else had the rule book
for life
and and i didn't and i walked around
with this kind of low-grade discomfort
with who i was i was very insecure
i had difficulty connecting with other
you know human beings
i was very much and still to this day
you know very much an introvert
and i think that that kind of um creates
this sense of separateness from
everybody else
and when you're young you're not
consciously aware of what's actually
going on you just know that you feel a
little bit different
and then when that moment arises and you
come in contact with that substance
that um that eases that sense of
discomfort
you just start to develop a relationship
with that because you're like wow this
is
actually makes me feel good so you're
correct in that
it's not the substance that's the
problem the underlying condition is the
problem
and the path in recovery is healing
yourself like obviously abstinence is a
big part of it you can no longer
you know use those substances anymore
but
without these spiritual tools and these
emotional tools and therapy and all the
like
you're still left with that condition
which if left untreated
you may not use drugs or drink anymore
but you're probably gonna be an [ __ ]
and you're gonna be unhappy right so
this is something that even though
it's been a very long time since my last
drink i still live with alcoholism and
if i'm not
treating that underlying condition
my disease will manifest itself in a
wide variety of
character defects that make everyone
else around me unhappy
myself included i think that that there
is
not necessarily a why and investigating
that
you know has a range of possible
outcomes and virtues and also
problems uh and so for the folks out
there again
um people tuning in from all over the
world already
just heartfelt and connected based on
your vulnerability
i feel like that the my understanding of
this gear shift that you made just based
on our previous conversations and
time hanging out by your pool in los
angeles with you is is a very inspiring
journey
and part of what i appreciated the most
is this willingness to just put one foot
in front of the other and
as you said you know there was no
individual light bulb moment
or um and it was just a series of
small decisions on over time can you
help us
understand a little bit about what some
of those steps were
i think we talk about self-care and it's
easy to couch it in
um you know in in that but give us
some tactics there because there are so
many people who look at you know your
podcast today one of the top 100
podcasts in the world
best-selling book one of the ones we're
about to get to get into
and where they are right now they look
they're looking at where you are
and you know they don't necessarily see
a path so help us understand help us
understand the path
that you chose in order to
create the the life and living that
you're you're living today
yeah sure so you know the path is always
crystal clear in retrospect you know
looking backwards
you can have perfect 20 20 clarity about
how you got to where you are
now um but casting that glance forward
is always um is always tricky uh and
like i said initially
you know i didn't i wasn't quite clear
on what the path was that i was blazing
other than that i was trying to you know
trust my instincts and develop
and develop and hone those i would say
that
if you google me on the internet
there's a narrative that emerges that
makes it look like everything that i've
accomplished happened in a very
compressed period of time and that's
an illusion like that is not the case
like i've been i'm 54 now
you know i got sober at 31 i started to
really you know deal with this
existential crisis
in my early 40s you know this is this is
we're talking about
decades of you know very slow gradual
progressive growth
uh along the way there certainly have
been inflection
points there was the day that i decided
i can't drink anymore and i'm going to
go to a treatment center and live there
for 100 days and that was a decision
that had a tremendous profound impact on
you know my entire life and continues to
this day and there was also the moment
10 years later when i was walking up a
flight of stairs and
was winded and out of breath and had
tightness in my chest and realized i
can't live my life the way that i'm
living it anymore
and that was a second inflection point
that's set in motion a series of very
small decisions that have led me to
today
but the important thing to remember is
that this is slow it's almost
imperceptible in the day-to-day
and i was able to go from those you know
dark places
by dint of inflection points that were
motivated by
pain and then in you know
subsequent to that figuring out how to
show up every single day
and just make you know tiny little
decisions a little bit better than i
did the day before like and focusing
really on the moment that i'm in or the
hour that i'm in what is the next meal
that i'm going to have what's that going
to look like
you know who's the next person that i'm
going to call am i going to sit on the
couch tonight and watch tv
or am i going to go to an a meeting or
you know what is
what is you know a creative outlet for
this
um sense of dis dissatisfaction that i
have
should i write a blog post should i
journal and it was really
a function of just showing up for tiny
little things like that
every single day and not even really
understanding that i was progressing
in the least and only over time that
change being reflected back to me by
other people who would say you look
better or
wow you seem to be a little bit lighter
in your shoes today
in the way that you're interacting with
me things that i wasn't even consciously
aware of
and that gave me the encouragement to
just more deeply immersed myself
in a variety of disciplines whether it
was you know fitness
diet nutrition therapy 12-step you know
being of service to helping other
alcoholics achieve sobriety
and then over time learning that
i picked up a few things along the way
and perhaps i could share those
and be of service to other people who
aren't quite as far along on this
journey as i am
how far how far into your journey did
the did it go from an an internal
exclusively an internal dialogue until
you
put it put that as an external part of
who you were
the like i'm i am far enough along
now and i can start to help others
it wasn't until probably 2008
uh 2000 yeah i think around 2008 when i
was really training for some of these
ultra endurance races that i was
competing in
um a buddy of mine bought richroll.com
that you are
like a tech buddy of mine bought the url
and gave it to me for my birthday
it never occurred to me that i would
want or need that and
he helped me create a blog and so i
started sharing
what my training was looking like and
how you know what the foods that i was
eating that was fueling my training
and this was something that you know not
even my mother was reading
like nobody nobody was reading but
slowly i started to pick up a small
audience i mean i certainly wasn't part
of that
early wave of internet creators that
people like yourself were
you know really very much a part of
people like yourself and tim ferriss
like i wasn't in that
category of individuals whatsoever but i
was aware of you guys and that was
inspiration to me
to say hey maybe i'll share a few things
i didn't really
set out to become an internet
personality it was just the era of where
everyone was kind of blogging a little
bit as a diary you know like this
personal journey
but some people started reading it and
what happened was
um sanjay gupta at cnn
somehow stumbled up across my blog and
was reading it because he was inching up
on 40 at the time and and thinking about
you know how he wanted to stay in
contact with his fitness
and he wanted to interview me and he
came out to my house
this was like a mind-blowing thing for
me at the time like we were going
through financial difficulties and i was
still
very confused about what i was doing and
it was just you know it was
bizarre that somebody like him would
show any interest whatsoever and what i
was doing because
it really was just for me it was a very
internal kind of thing
not that externally focused but in the
wake of that
they also asked me to write a blog post
an article about my story for cnn.com
which i did not thinking very much about
it and that
um that that piece uh got so much
traffic that they moved it from the
health section to the home page of cnn
and it became like the one of the top
most emailed stories for
that week or a couple days there and my
inbox just
exploded with people emailing me from
all over the world
sharing their version of my story and
these
messages were so intimate and vulnerable
i felt like people were
telling me things that they'd never told
anyone because i had led with
vulnerability and
and you know had the the kind of you
know courage to share things about
myself and my story that i wasn't
necessarily proud of
and that was another kind of inflection
point that
really made me think a little bit more
broadly
about what i was doing like the fact
that so many people took time out of
their day to email me
made me realize that perhaps there was
something about what i was doing
that meant more than just you know
whether i was going to finish this race
you know and that there was perhaps the
deeper message
um that that would allow me to you know
connect with with
people in a more profound and meaningful
manner
well we are all thankful of your
for your shift to the external external
locus
because it's benefited so many people uh
david hana talks about on on your
youtube channel right now where we're
live streaming this
says once you align with your core
values it doesn't matter what other
people think
and i'm interested in what role your
core values played
in this sort of internal external
dialogue
yeah i mean the first thing was that i
had to
determine what those core values were
like i i had been living my life
essentially for others for a very long
time i was trying to meet social
expectations and parental expectations
as i mentioned earlier
and always feeling like i was coming up
short and i had this undeniable sense
that i was
trying to jam a square peg into a round
hole but as
a swimmer as an athlete as a young
person like i knew how to suffer and i
just thought well
i'm just going to suffer through this
because this is what you do as
an adult until i reached my breaking
point with all of that
and made this decision that um i was
going to start paying attention to what
made me happy
and i can't overstate what a radical
notion that was for me at the time as
this like people pleaser who was
really just seeking uh approval
and external validation from people that
i really shouldn't have been you know i
should have been paying more attention
to what makes
me tick and makes me happy and you know
initially
i just discovered that that when i went
out
and went trail running or went back to
the pool or
rode my bicycle that it that it allowed
me to connect with a certain kind of
childlike joy that i hadn't experienced
in a long time i
very clearly made a decision that i was
going to continue to do that
even though you know i was battling this
demon that was saying
that's for kids that's not for adults
like you're supposed to be
you know going out and making bread and
you know
making your way in the world and this
didn't seem to fit into that
um equation but i just thought i don't
care like i'm
i'm gonna make time for the things that
make me happy and i don't
i don't you know not that it needs to
lead anywhere else other than
that but by continuing to just kind of
pull on that thread
and trying to explore it more a little
bit more deeply
i started to develop a sense of what my
core values were and those core values
you know over time have become
taking care of myself being a cipher for
others about how to do this
and being a message of hope for people
that suffer from
addiction and you know various disorders
that there is
um that there you know there is a path
forward and that a better life
awaits you if you're willing to do the
work and
slowly over time trying to craft a life
and a professional vocation around those
values really
and staying committed to that um is
really you know what's allowed me to
uh you know have some level of longevity
in the the thing that both you and i do
so inspiring um man when i think about
your what your message about um
your core value is you just
whether you were conscious of this or
not you talked about mindset over and
over and over there
and you know i i know that you're a deep
believer in this but i'm wondering if
you can share a little bit of detail
i'm also referencing a question from
youtube from matt
angiono how do we keep
a growth mindset and continue progress
because success
almost almost always he says results in
more consumption so you know what role
has mindset played in that for you and
what are some
things that you do to manage it um
that's a great question how do i answer
this i mean i think
when growth is part of that core value
set
um then everything else just becomes
tactics and strategies you know i know
that i'm committed to growth and
i've experienced a tremendous amount of
growth in my life but i also
know that there's so much more growth to
be had
right and i think understanding that i
still have
huge blind spots and that i'm still
my my worst enemy more more days
than not um keeps me uh connected
with the fact that there's more there's
more to do
but i think on a day-to-day basis it's
um
humility is super important you know
despite having success
understanding that i'm you know a
servant among men
and that my message is only as powerful
as as you know the kind of vibration
that i carry and if i'm not
living that myself you can't be
um a beacon for that you know in in
in a they call it uh not being able to
transmit something that you haven't got
right which is why sponsorship is such a
important part of of the recovery
process
because the sponsor has to be practicing
the principles
in order to be teaching them or helping
somebody else through that process so
humility
is key and then i think um
maintaining you know having having a
uh system of accountability is also
super important like i have friends that
i'm accountable to and they're not
afraid to tell me
when i'm screwing up or taking the wrong
tack
so i've learned over time that despite
becoming a more integrated person that
my instincts aren't always leading me in
the right direction like anybody else
i'm
you know i i can be the victim of ego
and all these kind of lower character
defects that can lead me astray
and so i make a habit of running my
decisions by
kind of a you know council of
of advisors who help me make right
decisions so
i have the humility to not think that i
always know what's best for myself
and to make sure that i'm getting input
from people that i trust that's super
important so
community essentially like making sure
that you're keeping good company
people that are encouraging and positive
but also honest with you
i think is super important and then i
think
second to that ensuring that you're
uh creating healthy boundaries around
the things that don't serve you
and also carving out the time for
that self-care you know we're all so
busy and we have our careers and
families and relationships etc and it's
very easy
to live your life on autopilot it's
particularly easy to do that when things
are going well
because there is an incentive to do kind
of an inventory
of you know how you're living your life
moments a moment or day to day
so i try to make sure that every single
day
before i start my day i ground myself
with meditation
with journaling with a gratitude list
and
staying in contact you know with my
friends and that board of advisors to
make sure that you know we're all
communicating with each other
and we're a mutual support system for
each other
i love it uh teresa from youtube's
grateful that you're talking about this
and she
like so many of us struggle from
self-sabotage
you just cited a panel of advisors a
peer group
and i'm wondering and i think a lot of
people who are watching are listening
might be wondering
how does one go about finding that group
because there's so much loneliness and
isolation not just because we're here in
a pandemic
but in modern culture and there are
people right now listening and watching
saying awesome well
if i'm the average of the five people i
spend the most time with how do i find
myself or put myself around people
who um have growth mindset who are
living their
highest values or people that i can ask
to hold me to a different standard that
i might hold myself to or than my
current peer group so
how did you find that group and uh and
what is some advice
that you would give others who are
struggling there
yeah that's a that's a great question
you know i think
that um we live in this culture
what's what's kind of great about this
kind of internet ecosystem that we're
in is that there are a lot of inspiring
people who are
basically dropping wisdom on the daily
and and uh and and that information is
freely available and some of these
people
become rock stars like everybody would
love seth godin to be
their you know their mentor you know
like will you mentor me there
there are certain personalities out in
the world and and we
we rightly put a um
spotlight on them and we all aspire to
have somebody of that caliber in our
life
but that's not a possibility for most
people and i think it's important to
understand
you know one of my favorite catch
phrases is you know the prophets walk
among us you know there are
wise people walking planet earth
in our particular neighborhoods and
environments
if you just give people a chance and you
know some of
the most um
wise and intelligent advisors that i
have in my life
are not anybody fancy that anybody would
have heard of they're
you know they're they're like broken
down
you know drunks and heroin addicts who
piece their life together and are just
you know living their life anonymously
you know as a servant
and you know these are the people that
are like the buddhas in my life so i
think
it's important my point being that you
know stop worrying about the fancy
people
and and really start paying attention to
the people that are in your environment
and i think when you do that and you
engage those people
in an honest and open way leading with
curiosity and vulnerability i think you
might be
surprised at who you will discover
um short of that we do have
this thing called the internet and and
like i said
you know a lot of wisdom is freely
available and that doesn't mean
that you know you might might not be
able to get these people on the phone to
become your mentors but there's a lot of
guidance
out there and i think if you you know
seek it out
um that can fill the gap uh if you're
having trouble finding those people
you know in your day-to-day life and
particularly you know
given that you know we're in this age of
coronavirus where
we can't socialize you know on the level
that we would like
but i would encourage everybody to you
know
go through their rolodex or think about
their childhood friends
and to use this moment this zoom culture
that we're in right now to reconnect
with those people
and i think if you're in that curious
exploratory
mindset you you might surprise yourself
with the people that
that you can find and enlist in this
process and i
in closing to that question i think if
you approach those people
from a perspective of mutual mutuality
like how can i help you and create
like a a dynamic where you're helping
each other
and you can grow together you know that
at a very minimum
is an extremely powerful level for
growth
well rossum photography from anchorage
alaska radonna
emmett uh catherine just
dreamed from l.a brittany from canada
matt shepard nice to see you in the
comments here matt shepard people from
all over the world are
starting to are chiming in here in the
comments
but our in awe with
the simplicity and directness that you
are able to
articulate this now that is a skill
but have you done extra work
on this is this about is this about
mental clarity is this about
clarity of vision for your life where
does
this laser that you have for this stuff
come from
uh i mean i i you know i don't know i
mean i
first of all thank you like i'm not
aware that i'm doing that
and i'm always trying it's like a laser
beam it's like i'm always
checking myself like am i full of [ __ ]
is that just like total [ __ ]
um you know listen i think uh
i think going to law school uh was was
was very helpful in teaching me
how to think and analyze problems
and articulate a point of view clearly
and make and make an argument and then
support it like it's a very specific
skill set that teaches you a mentality
around advocacy and rhetoric so i think
that was helpful
um and i think you would agree chase
uh i don't know how many episodes of
your show you've done but i've done
over 550 so that's like i don't know how
many thousands of hours of talking to
people
but um you know that just that just you
know goes into your
you know unconscious mind and you know
when you're forced to be present with
another individual and talk to them for
long periods of time
hopefully over time you get better at
doing that
and you become more skilled at
articulating your your your ideas and
your views
it's i just find it so useful to listen
to you
and i do believe in your point that the
this conversation seeking out smart
talented people
you know it my show started out 11 years
ago as
a curiosity project and
almost selfishly like how do i learn
from these folks who inspire me
and i i like that you you phrase it as
as sort of this
um it is a skill that you've worked on
over time and that's part of the reason
i want to circle back to your point
about community like if you're just
sitting alone on the couch
and you're thinking instead of acting
and you
you don't have other folks that you can
bounce things
off of that as you said are your
accountability partners or
you know you're an advisory council if
you will
it's just it's just a lot harder and
this belief that these things happen
as individual pursuits i think is one of
the most toxic things in our culture
it's why i wrote so much about it in my
book creative calling a core
the book was dedicated to community
um david asks
i don't hear you talk much about god and
i hear you talk about faith
which is obviously very personal so
under the umbrella
of faith who are some of these
influential people in your life i i
think you could say this is an extension
of the question that i just asked like
you said there are people in the 12-step
program that inspire you
and people in your life are these close
friends are they people that are on the
internet that you reached out to is it
someone in your immediate circle family
members
can i just sense this just based on the
questions coming in
people are are hungry now like great
where do i
look um yeah interesting
i think uh that
it's a tricky question uh
i would say that i believe in god but i
don't believe
in you know a dogmatic application of
religion
particularly so my faith doesn't take
um some kind of organizational form
and my spiritual inspiration comes from
a wide swath
of you know wise what i would consider
to be
enlightened or semi-enlightened
individuals and i
really care less about the tradition
that they you know in which they
developed their perspective
and i care more about what that wisdom
is and how it applies to my life so
i've sought this out in a variety of
ways i seek it out
um in in uh an alcoholics anonymous you
know my my first introduction like i'm
somebody who grew up
in sunday school and i went to an
episcopal you know elementary school and
i just
never was able to connect with religion
like i had no emotional
attachment to it whatsoever i just i
could not wrap my head around
how this could be helpful in my life and
when i was in
this treatment center uh one of the
counselors said to me early on
uh he asked me a question he said are
you a human being having a spiritual
experience or a spiritual being having a
human experience
and i was like i don't [ __ ]
understand the question
like i it like bent my brain like trying
to figure out what he was getting at and
it's only
you know over a long period of time that
i've come to realize
that you know i'm a spiritual being
having a human experience
and what does that mean specifically i'm
still trying to answer that question
but i do believe that we are more than
the sum of our parts
and that there are uh is
such a vastness to the universe it's
hard for me to believe that it's that
it's random and i think there are so
many things that
escape our limited our limited senses
and
perceptions to understand and i take i
take comfort
in not knowing that and the guidance
that i get
comes from you know the monks who've
been in caves and the
you know the kundalini yoga masters and
the you know uh you know the reformed
pastors like
all walks of life and i've tried to use
the podcast as a platform for some of
these people that come and share their
stories i mean i've had
everybody from rob bell who was a former
mega
mega pastor you know who's kind of you
know
reframed his relationship with with you
know christ and christianity
to you know rodney swami who comes from
you know the hari krishna movement uh
and and kind of everything in between
and i i think when you
approach these people from a perspective
again
you know of humility and curiosity it
opens up your portal
to learn you know something about
something about yourself
and uh and how to live
well speaking of your podcast which is
one of the top in the world
more than 100 million downloads i want
to
share with everyone your new book voice
and change
which to your point of uh the prophet's
walk
among among us i will just share with
you i have
the good fortune of having it
[Music]
right there the the prophets walk among
us which is
show everybody show everybody the the
profile of you in there i was so proud
to include chase
in the book yeah we have some beautiful
photographs that we took of you from
that day
um let's see i'll give you a look at the
table of contents here real quick
the photographs are beautiful as a
lifelong photographer myself i want to
give you a shout out uh you and your
crew for putting
together it's amazing um aggregate of
photographs
from so many different um moments in
your
in the show lifestyle moments outside
from
outside of the show let's see
one there's timmy ferris another dear
friend of ours
oh look there we are right there yeah
on page one five four for for anyone who
cares
there he is and thanks for that you're
me kicking it to your place in
l.a that was a really really fun day
certainly one of my favorite interviews
i've ever given
haven't given a lot been on a lot of
shows um
your your craft your ability to get to
the heart of stuff
is uh like few that i've been in
um close proximity to it was a very very
fun experience to be on the show
i still get people um like you know
sending me whatever
dm's in instagram about how it has been
helpful so shout out to you for your
craft as someone who's also been doing
it for
for a decade or more uh but i wanna
i want to make sure to underscore and
connect the dots from
where we just were to this particular
book
you talked about you know we had a lot
of questions about okay i'm stuck and i
understand that
i'm one person i have a set of core
values
but what i really need in order to
maximize or even
[Music]
just increase my potential
is a community and sometimes especially
now
it's like chronovirus but just in pop
culture generally it's hard to build
relationships
and maintain them and develop them and i
like
that you referenced you know in the
question about
sort of faith and about who in your life
inspires you
it it was a huge swath you know it was
people
from 12-step meetings and you know
religious leaders and you know
scientists and astronauts and athletes
and
it zoo keepers it literally was the
entire gamut
and it's captured in here and i think
that is
you know when people ask the question
how do i get in stuck
if it's anything this book is a book of
life lessons about reaching out and
building a relationship with people who
inspire
or connect with you in your case you're
you're
face to face with them having long
heartfelt earnest conversations
but would it be a stretch to say that
your relationship with those people at
first
started out from a distance uh as
someone you were inspired by
so walk us through your you know
with most of these people you had to pay
attention to their work read their books
listen to their podcasts to their shows
before you connected to them what was
the
what's that what's a typical arc look
like because clearly you've
you've mastered it here in the book yeah
thank you
um you know much like yourself
i started the podcast out of you know
curiosity and this desire to grow
it was never intended to be this
vocation you know i
i had kind of progressed as a human
being to a certain point and i'd have
been able to accomplish certain things
in terms of
athletic achievements and the like and
it became apparent to me that
like i said earlier like growth you know
growth is not static growth continues
and i wanted to continue to progress
as an individual on this realization
like wow i changed my life so much and
i've come so far and i've done these
things like
what else am i blind to like where are
the other areas that i can explore to
continue to grow
as a human being and the podcast really
is a very you know honest and heartfelt
um expression of of that journey
and my litmus test for having somebody
on the show
is really just oh i'm curious about that
person and that person is doing
something i want to learn more about
that could
perhaps benefit me but also i think you
know
they just they deserve you know
attention and credit for what they're
doing
um and you know i've never set out with
goals like he's the people i want to get
on the show like it it's all very like
organic like i'll just wake up one day
or i'll read an article and i'll think
that person's cool like i'm going to
reach out to that person
and sometimes it takes a year before i
mean it took us a long time to get it
together to make it happen
so i'm always like babysitting you know
these relationships trying to get people
on the show and what's beautiful about
it
is that you know very often they become
part of that council of you know
advisors in my life and my friends you
know like
you know even though we haven't spent
that much time together i do feel very
connected to you
and i know if i was to you know fly up
to seattle that we could hang out all
weekend and have an unbelievable time
like
you know i i feel connected to you and
there's something about sitting across
from a person
uh in a structured environment and
having a long-form conversation
and really you know with the intention
of it being heartfelt and meaningful
that creates this bond like i'll never
forget the experience that we had and i
know when you walk away like you'll
remember that as well and we like have
that and there's something really
special about that and so understanding
that
motivates me to be as prepared as i
possibly can you know i i
i have them on because
i do want to know more about them so of
course i'm going to read the book and
like you know
watch all their videos and listen to the
other podcasts they've done
um because you know i i want that energy
in my own life from a selfish
perspective
and it makes me a better host but then
when i show up for the interview
as you know you kind of have to let all
that go and just be present for
whatever's happening and get out of the
business of trying to control
a conversation because then you're
robbing it of
what's most beautiful about it which is
just the emotional connection that can
develop when two people
are just present with each other and
aren't like you know caught up in some
agenda so i think that's what's really
beautiful about it and and i think you
would echo
um you know another sentiment that i
have about about this journey which is
that it's taught me
how important meaningful conversation is
like i i
truly believe in my heart of hearts now
more than ever
that meaningful conversation is
is the salve to what ails us you know we
just weathered this
very acrimonious election um regardless
of
who you voted for or whatever your
political proclivity is
we're not we're all keyed into the fact
that we're
quite divided as a country right now and
there's a breakdown in our ability
to engage in healthy communication with
each other
and the problem is is dire
and the only solution that i can
identify
for moving forward is to double down on
on
you know these kind of long-form
meaningful conversations that prioritize
nuance that aren't binary they're not
black or white it's not about what tribe
you're in
but it's really about trying to develop
mutual
understanding and i just think it's
super crucial and critical
in this you know clickbait sound bite
culture
where everyone assumes we're attention
deprived the fact that
podcasting long-form conversations are
having this kind of
moment where they've never been more
popular i think speaks to
something that's hardwired into all of
us as human beings like this
is you know the human the this is
ancient man sitting
at the campfire you know connecting with
his fellow human and
we've lost touch with that and these
digital platforms have allowed us to
recapture
um some aspect of that and i think
the appreciation for the medium you know
it
is really an affirmation of just how
important and critical
this is in being you know fully
actualized healthy human beings
that uh care about you know a healthy
society
so well said very very well said and i
think that
i would just echo the sentiment of
conversation starts with a if it starts
from
humility and from a question rather than
a point of view and an ego yeah i think
that is one of the
biggest challenges that i observe
in other people trying to connect and
converse
and it's one that i've experienced
having done hundreds and hundreds of
conversations like the one that we're
recording and
um you know we keep saying like you know
my man you know we keep referring to the
other person because we walked in
such a similar path um i also found it
fascinating like you just mentioned the
digital ecosystem as a way to share
ideas
and you know spread this knowledge and
encourage
conversation demonstrate model if you
will
open honest heartfelt conversation in
the time that we need it
i found it just fascinating and
brilliant that you packaged
conversations into a book you know one
of the things that i
was reluctant to do for some time was
actually sit down and spend a couple of
years
writing a book because it was a meeting
that was slow
for me i enjoy the benefits of writing
but writing is hard
and you know it took a couple of years
to put what i felt were
my sort of like collection of ideas into
a book
and i just found it so fulfilling mostly
because there are people who were
new to my work or new to um
creativity or creative curious or heard
about it from a friend it was like
another package to get
out the information that i had been
sharing digitally for a long time
i'm curious now to get to the actual the
punchline
the question there was that an
intentional move to package
digital conversation into an analog
package that was giftable that was
readable that was
bedside table this is this is a
combination of coffee table book because
the photography is beautiful
and inspiring as hell
uh with with the words and the excerpts
from your shows what was the impetus
behind this
um i think you nailed it
you know it i think that as a digital
creator
you can get lulled into this idea
that because you have fans that are
paying attention to what you're doing
that they're watching every episode you
know of your show
and reading every blog post and that's
just not
the way that human beings are and you
know
over the course of the eight years that
i've been doing this i've put up
episodes that were you know seven years
ago that i could
you know release today that are just as
timely as and just as important but
there's this idea that because
it's in the past that it's not really
relevant anymore
um even if you you know couch it as
timeless
and i wanted to i think there is
something you know yeah writing is hard
and it's it's it's painful but when you
get to the other side of it it is
it is very gratifying and one aspect of
that gratification is that there's
something
physical that exists in the world you
know
that is a manifestation a
crystallization of the message that you
know the frequency that you're trying to
you know admit and the book really was
motivated
by that sentiment you know understanding
like not everybody listens to every
podcast
there are a lot of people that don't
listen to podcasts at all or they don't
have time
and i wanted to to you know take a
cross-section
of all these guests that i've had create
and you know a fair and accurate you
know representation
a vibe of what the show is with nuggets
of wisdom
from past guests like yourself essays
contributed by
certain people of course my thoughts and
package it
in a very aesthetically pleasing manner
like
you know as a photographer and a
filmmaker chase you know like aesthetics
that are important
i care about aesthetics and i wanted i
wanted the book to represent
that kind of the kind of ethos um that
i'm trying to
you know create around the show that i
do and the ideas that
are important to me and do it in a way
where people could
either revisit their their favorite
guests in the past
rediscover new people or
as an introduction for somebody who's
never heard of anything that i do
before to get a sense of of what it's
all about
in a very you know digestible way and in
a format that somebody can put out on
their coffee table
and feel good about somebody a guest
coming in
and and flipping through it this is like
a trojan horse
i had it set out and my wife kate is a
huge fan
loves your work the cookbook that you
and your wife did is
the first one she's always reaching for
she's getting more and more plant-based
and
when i had this sitting on the coffee
table uh this was i think last night
because i just got it two days ago
um and it i just
i watched her pick it up
ask me anything just start flipping
stopping
reading you know and then 20 minutes
later she's still like
glued to this thing and then i said hey
you know i've got i got rich on the show
tomorrow and she's like oh my god i feel
like i know him
and again i don't think you've spent any
time with with kate but
the ability in 20 minutes to have
you know got this trojan horse that in a
way it turns not just your guests but
it's a reflection of you and i thought
that was a really
like kate kate's comment about feeling
like she knows who
you are just by reading largely your
guest's commentary but
based on the questions and the packaging
of this i think
it's it's such an amazing trojan horse
um
for the ideas that are important to you
i i don't know if that was intentional
but it's like what is it the sugar with
the medicine
yeah i appreciate that that's great
feedback yeah i mean you know pull them
in
with the uh beautiful photography and
then hit them over the hammer with the
timeless wisdom
you just yeah you coined that that's a
good one and uh
can we talk about your your creative
process for a minute mm-hmm
yeah so uh
i i want to recap there we go uh
farmer lawyer and i remember from our
previous conversations
if i'm making this up then you kick me
into the table here
but as a lawyer or before
your lawyerness i don't
remember i think you didn't really
identify
as creative i think as you said in your
sort of intro salvo just you know a lot
about pleasing other people and that was
about achievement and ticking boxes and
whatnot
so two two-part question first part
at what point in your journey did you
understand
that we're all creative specifically you
were very creative
and then two talk about what your
creative process
looks like today
i think that that on an unconscious
level
i always knew that i was a creative
person
and before all the kind of you know
messaging that ended up muting that
voice uh i found a lot of joy
in creative expression you know i
remember picking
up a camera when i was you know a
freshman in college and i started taking
photographs
of uh the swim team at stanford and then
at the end of the year i do a slideshow
for them and i i found so much
creative satisfaction in that even
though it was just a silly little
project
but what happened to me and i think this
is common with a lot of people it just
gets pushed aside like
that's an indulgence like that's not
really what you're here to do
this is not what you're meant to be
fostering you have to get serious and
grow up
and so i suppressed all of those
instincts that i think we all have
you know especially when we're children
and for me
it's been a journey of trying to
reconnect and and recapture that
um and to honor it really like and not
look at it like
a frivolous indulgence but actually to
take it seriously and
my creative process has evolved over
time really by
um by that process of honoring it and
you know creating boundaries
around creative time for myself and this
began for me
by doing the artist's way program and
going on the artist date
and like trying new things even though
it was silly
and then um feeling really like kind of
secretly
proud of myself or you know doing a
little
you know going out in the woods and like
drawing a picture or something like
that um and it's evolved over time now
into you know products like books that i
get that i get to put out and
you know like we talked about earlier um
aesthetics
you know are important to me and i've
kind of honed that sensibility over time
and this book in particular i think is a
a pretty good
accurate reflection of of
of you know how i approach my work in
the sense that
there's a very modern veneer over this
book in particular
like it has a modern sensibility in its
typeface
and in the types of photographs and
the manner in which they're laid out but
that's very intentional
and the intentionality is about taking
like these arcane ideas that are
somewhat ephemeral
and very often you know rooted in
you know ancient philosophy and religion
and uh you know places that um
you know you you would find these ideas
in like dusty old books
or in the you know the kind of
bodhi tree bookstore where there's a
bunch of hippies and i wanted to
kind of reframe the conversation that
we're having around these ideas and
present it
in a modern way that makes it kind of
aspirational
and digestible for a modern audience and
that was kind of my
idea going into this book and i should
say that this was very
much a team effort you know like i i
worked with some really amazing
and talented photographers and graphic
designers
who uh who are responsible truly for you
know the look and the feel
and the layout of what this book is and
it's a book that
even though i really got to work
writing it and finishing it at the
beginning of the pandemic and now
releasing it as self-published volume
it's something i've been working on from
the beginning of the podcast because
i've always put
a lot of time and attention into the
introductory blog post that i write for
every guest
and i constantly flogging myself because
i know that such a small percentage of
the audience even ever
reads these things or cares about these
things and i was doing it really for
myself like to continue to progress and
evolve as a writer like
how can i say something interesting and
unique about this
individual and the conversation to come
while also
communicating their bio and the
essential facts and the things that you
kind of have to do
but what's different about how i can
introduce this person
from how somebody else is doing it and
the book is really
an assemblage of all of these blog posts
that i then you know
re-edited and rewrote so that they're
appropriate for the book but
you know that work you know began at the
beginning of the podcast so in certain
respects i've been writing this book
ever since i
started doing the show well to your
first point about the process of putting
a
modern package
around timeless ideas i just give you
five stars on that one my man and you
crushed it
and that's really what i meant when i
said this sort of trojan horse
sitting on my coffee table just i
watched it suck except kate
in and you know deliver and
you shoot you and she are you remind me
of one another a lot in your
approach to life um so on the first
point about the package
you nailed it and i've got living proof
i got i watched it
last night so uh fully uh
executed well on that one so the second
point about your process
um this idea of
doing a daily practice is something that
you know i'm personally obsessed with i
think you know habits and
behaviors or how we actually make change
in our lives and
you've done 500 of these interviews and
you talked about writing every day what
is your daily practice or
creativity do you have one or is it just
weekly is it all around the show are
there some other
avenues that you like to express
yourself so um you know talk
to us about what what rich role wakes up
and does
either every day or in a week what's
your frequency and how do you think
about your creative timing
you said earlier you you intentionally
block time for
yeah i mean i think fundamentally first
and foremost
uh my creativity is is probably best
expressed
as a writer i think i do a variety of
creative things and i try to be creative
with
how i do the podcast and you know what
the set is going to look like like all
these little details like
i think are all you know creative
outlets for exploration that i'm always
trying to
kind of evolve and iterate on but the
one thing that i
that i do the most diligently
is is writing and that may be writing an
introductory blog post for a podcast or
it may be
in a particular approach to a journal
entry that day but that's the thing that
i'm practicing most consistently
um you know i have fun with instagram
and photography i'm certainly no
professional photographer
uh but i enjoy you know the visual
medium and i'm somebody who learns
visually
and i'm very aware that that's kind of
the um the process through which i
i'm able to kind of
synthesize information and i care about
the visual image so i love playing
around i've got a bunch of different
cameras and i t
i take tons of pictures that i don't
share on instagram and i just do it
for myself and i think there's also
something
important about that like not everything
needs to be
shared and i think a lot of the you know
creative process or cultivation of your
creative spirit
should be something that you protect and
should be just for yourself it doesn't
always have to be
and in many cases shouldn't be for
consumption this is a relationship
between
you and you fundamentally
very well said i like that duality and i
do believe deeply in creating and
sharing as a mechanism or as a muscle
that you develop so that you can
get things out in more raw fashion that
doesn't
involve so much judgment that we often
all carry around
but the other side this the personal
development side and not sharing
everything and
you know whether that's journaling or
any examples you get
i think that that is a really important
duality that must be maintained
and um doesn't not a lot of folks talk
about that
uh you and i have also on previous shows
and if you haven't listened to them well
first of all
uh where there's youtube comments coming
in from john ulster on youtube live
has been one of the best podcasts i've
ever listened to by either of you
arnoldson says this is an amazing
discussion as a photographer and
influencer have been so inspired by our
weird
journey really appreciate the authentic
and humble approach so
to keep that going this idea of this
humility that you
have a respect for
the different media that you've been
experimenting with
and also traditional publishing channels
the first couple of books if i'm not
mistaken were
were through major publishers you know
and this one here it seems to
be something you self-published talk to
me about
that process yeah so self-publishing is
something that
that has always interested me um the
other books that that i've done and that
my wife and i have done together have
all been
with traditional publishers and i've
learned a lot about how that world works
and what that process is all about
and you know i've got a lot of love for
it as well like it
you know it put it put me on the map as
an author and you know
i've i've you know had a fantastic
experience working with editors and and
publishing houses
so this is not us this book our decision
to
self-publish it is not a slight against
that but i wanted to
from a creative point of view
learn about what it would be like
to create a book in-house control every
facet
of its creation it's manufacturing
it's production all the way down to the
details like on the cover you have this
like
it's a matte finish but then there's
kind of a raised rib on it like all
these tiny little decisions that you
make
i think are really cool and fun and i
wanted to be able to um
be part of every aspect of that without
having somebody tell me no you can't do
that or
we have to do it this way and then
to really control the distribution of it
from
pillar to post
for a couple reasons one is this is a
very
specific type of book it's an expensive
book
given that it's expensive and you know
multi-color with all the photographs and
all the like
i'm just not in a position where a
publisher is going to offer the kind of
advance that i think this book desire
you know deserves because it's an
expensive book to produce
and it's not the kind of book where
you're trying to make the new york times
bestseller list like i don't care about
any of that like this is a book for the
fans this is a book
um uh that's like a keepsake um
and um this is an unbelievable gift yeah
this is going to cr
i am personally going to give this to a
lot of people
this is like yeah you know i really i do
i i take pride in being able
to like oh man this is a great gift for
someone and these
this is just such a beautifully crafted
piece of art in and of itself that
amazing gift yeah i want to plug where
we can get the book here in a second but
yeah okay but yeah i interrupted you
which is just tragic because you were
crushing it on a roll around
this the ethos of making all these
decisions and and
that it wasn't something that you
cherished to be on the new york times it
was a different piece of art so sorry
keep going
yeah so it's really liberating to kind
of let go of like
you know pre-order campaigns and like
you know what are the pre-order sales
and what do the numbers look like like i
honestly don't care about any of that
like this is you know i understand that
this is like
a bit of a niche book and to kind of
liberate yourself from
shouldering those kind of expectations
is really nice um and i'm just sharing
it from the heart for people that you
know
that for whom you know it might resonate
with so there's that
and then um there's the fact that
i know that i can do a subsequent volume
like every year like i can put out
you know voicing change volume two next
year at this point and i can do that
year after year after year
and i wanted to be able to completely
own and control
that entire kind of small universe
um and fundamentally like it becomes a
more valuable asset over time you know
somebody like yourself who
you've done self-publishing and you've
you've written you know a published book
on a mass level you know the difference
and
you know five years later you're making
you know with the publisher you're
making a dollar
you know a copy once you earn out your
advance
and with this book you know we basically
you know we make what it
you know everything in advance of what
it costs to produce it
and that's been really you know cool and
awesome as well so
um there's a different kind of
kind of creative gratification i think
that comes with that because there
weren't a whole bunch of middlemen who
were making decisions for us
and everything reflected in the book is
a representation of the decision that
myself
and the the talented you know team that
i work with
made on a couple different occasions
start our conversation we've
whether you've said it and i've sort of
paraphrased it or i've said sort of the
other side of that same
coin how important is
for example in this coin doing both
having done
the self-published and the
uh the big publishing house
are there virtues to both yeah so
you know if so what what advice would
you give to others out there
because there are people who don't have
an option to use
a big publisher or to you know fill in
the blank
be on the cover of a magazine or hanging
in a gallery or whatever so
what advice would you have to those
folks and then there's other folks who
who have you know either been on that uh
the traditional track and you know maybe
missing out on this being able to
control things end to end so
what what advice would you give to
creators on both sides of that
same coin i mean there are pluses and
minuses on both sides of the equation
and i really think it's about what your
motivation is
if you want to write a best-selling book
that's going to get into the hands of as
many people as possible
uh the publishing houses are still the
way to go with something like that if
there's one thing that they know how to
do
they know how to distribute while uh
widely so
they know how to get the books into all
the bookstores and all the book sellers
um on some level you know they they sort
of know how to do publicity but you
really still have to shoulder that
yourself as you and i both know um
uh but um they they handle all the just
they handle all the things that you know
you don't really know how to do and most
people don't want to do like there's a
lot of people they just want to write
books
and they just want to focus on working
on the next book they don't want to
get involved in what the cover looks
like
and all the minor editing and the
typeface and all of that
and the publishing houses know how to do
that and they do it very well so if your
motivation is
i just want to write and i don't want to
deal with the rest of the stuff
then you're more likely to benefit from
going with a publisher
and if you're interested in you know the
book getting into
as many hands as possible the publishing
houses are still the best way to do that
like you said not everybody is in a
position to get a book deal
the good news is that now we live in a
world in which
not only is self-publishing more
and more nimble and available to
everybody the tools are easier to use
the
price points are coming down and the
accessibility
of self-publishing has never been more
facile and at the same time
um the uh
the stigma around self-publishing is is
starting to vanish there was a day not
too long ago where it's like oh you're
self-publishing well you must not have
been able to get a book deal
and now there's a celebration of
self-publishing and when you see a book
like
david goggins can't hurt me you know
which is he decided to self-publish that
book
and it's out there you know selling as
many copies as michelle obama's book
that's an unbelievable like bellwether
for
this paradigm shift in the publishing
world so i think we're going to see
more and more accessibility and
amenability
to people who are self-publishing and
there are lots of companies out there
who are there to hold your hand and walk
you through this process like we're
doing it all in-house and we're handling
distribution and i have
some infrastructure here so i can do
that but
most people don't and there are services
available that help you
with the production and with you know
all of the distribution needs that
you're going to
need um so i'd encourage anybody who
feels inspired to
write and to share their you know
creative spark
to explore the self-publishing world and
now
when you know people have large digital
platforms like yourself it calls into
question
the need for that um distribution
expertise that the publishing houses
bring to bear because
you have a huge audience and i have a
relatively large audience
and what is it like if i just reach out
to those people
and don't worry about whether barnes
noble is going to put one copy of it
in the corner of you know this gigantic
store where it might sit there for a
year is that really even
meaningful or important anymore and
particularly when we're in a pandemic
and nobody's going to bookstores anyway
what we're doing right now
is the most effective way to raise
awareness around books
and to get people interested in what you
have to say
beautifully well put i want to ask one
more follow-up there and pull on this
thread because you
framed your answer largely as i had
asked in the in the
around the the idea of books
but continue that same you know
theoretical or conceptual response and
apply that if you would
to just doing work that you are
self-publishing
in any industry whether that's podcast
or or others and you know continue to
riff if you would
on you know your thoughts about you know
you touched on it just briefly like it's
not about validation
you know whether you can and can't get a
book deal so uh expand on this thread
and apply it if you would to other
mediums in in maybe the form of some
advice
for people who are listening and saying
yeah yeah i might not be an author but
you know maybe i'm a photographer or a
designer or whatever
how do i go about either
you know i don't have access to the
platforms that you're talking about with
big publishers but
extend your advice beyond books and
keep the concept of you know you what
you believe
is possible or important in publishing
stuff on your own
yeah i mean i think the big idea here uh
is an idea that i certainly didn't come
up with i'll credit james altucher with
it which is
choose yourself and stop waiting
or asking for permission to do that
thing that inspires you
you know as somebody who's you know 54
years old and
and most likely older than almost you
know most of the people who are watching
this
you know i grew up in an era where the
gatekeepers were everywhere
and if you wanted to express yourself or
push something into the world whether
it's a photograph or a book or a record
or a movie there are so many people that
have to say
yes to that and it creates a culture in
which
it's less about the work and it's more
about how to figure out how to get all
of these gatekeepers to say
yes like that's where the creative
energy went rather than in the quality
of the ultimate work product that is
completely
shifted now where although there may
be some sense that you know you gotta
you got
you gotta you need people to sign off on
what it is that you're trying to do
so much of that is now illusion you know
yes if you
want to get a book published with a
traditional publisher there are people
that are going to have to say yes
if you want to get a feature film made
you're going to have to raise a bunch of
money and there's going to be a bunch of
people that have to say yes
but you don't need anybody to give you
permission
to edit you know a a movie that you shot
on your iphone
up on youtube you don't need permission
to hit publish on that blog post and you
certainly don't need permission
from anybody to self-publish a book so
whether
your creative impulse is you know visual
or literary or some other artistic
format you're a sculptor
or you want to create hoodies you know
you can do that now and
you can create your garment line you can
create your side hustle or your business
or whatever you know wherever that
creative inspiration is leading you
we live in this beautiful age where that
power
rests with the individual and that's
unprecedented and i don't think we talk
enough about just how powerful that is
so
whatever resistance or barrier that
you're experiencing or you feel like
well i'm not good enough or until
somebody validates me i'm just gonna
keep it to myself
that's the challenge and it require
that's where the inner work goes into
trusting yourself and stepping outside
of your comfort zone
and getting into a place of of faith
where
you share your your work product
liberally
you stay out of the you know the results
of that
and you engage more vigorously in that
creative muse
because you know and i say this all the
time and i'm sure you would agree with
me
right now what we need more than ever
is people who are
self-actualized and expressing the best
version of who they are in whatever
creative medium speaks to them
lasers man i'm telling you just like
lasik surgery on
my brain
that's um question for you bud and then
uh for those watching we are going to
bounce over to
my instagram at chase jarvis and you are
at rich roll and
answer a few questions from the
community that we couldn't get to here
in
in this the time constraints we had on
the show so we're going to bounce over
there in just a moment for
those of you who are watching live uh
and with a focus answering some
questions
um but as as an extension of your last
point and uh i think this really
underscores a lot of what you've talked
about with
self-actualization about you know moving
out of addiction to redemption
to your health and your creativity and
living the life
of your dreams this one precious life
that we all have
i like to say that the most important
words in the world are the ones that we
say to ourselves
and i'm curious if you could share your
thoughts
on that statement and uh and maybe by
example you know how or how do you
manage your own psychology in the words
that you say to yourself when facing
you know adversity and success because
they both have a dark side
yeah it's been a it's been an evolution
for me with this
i i love this question i think this is a
really important question and
i would say that my starting point with
this as embarrassing as it is to
say and admit is
that i was somebody and i still
combat this and confront this and i
think this is very
um endemic to alcoholics and recovering
alcoholics
the alcoholic mindset is unique in that
it can simultaneously entertain
the idea that you're better than
everyone else
and you know what's best and at the same
time think you're a complete
piece of [ __ ] who doesn't deserve to
breathe air
and those two ideas somehow find a way
to cohabitate with each other which
creates a confusing
you know psychological morass that i
lived with for a very long time
and and what i try to do now
is to again engage with humility and the
mantra that i repeat to myself
is that um that i'm enough
that i'm enough and i'm not defined by
what i do and how what i do is received
by the world
that um irrespective of any of that
that i'm a human being that has value
independent
of of you know what my career is or or
any of the other things and and that's
difficult for me you know i'm somebody
who really does gauge my
my um my value based upon
you know how successful i am or how good
i feel about the
creative thing that i just released into
the world
and it's it's difficult for me to
separate
uh myself from the actions
right and and that's kind of where the
battleground lives for me
spoken like a true sage
i don't know i want to give another one
last plug here
come on i got to give a fly for this
thing this is
just a stunning piece of art and
wisdom packaged voicing change
inspiration and timeless wisdom from the
ritual podcast
if you're not a subscriber to rich's
show you must
uh and i personally am going to be
giving this book a lot for the holidays
and uh would encourage everyone not
everyone probably gets a signed copy
like just to rub it just for a second
because i'm grateful
uh my man it's been so good to reconnect
with you uh
it's nice to see you are doing so well
love the beard
love it you get that it's a lovely point
of flair
um thanks so much for being on the show
and you are
a true uh a true hero to so many and an
inspiration your journey is
as you said well documented um but every
time we talk there are new nuggets that
i like to share
or that that i take away and that i'm
proud to share here on the show so thank
you so much for being a guest
i appreciate that man you've been an
inspiration to me for
many many years and nothing but crazy
mad respect for
everything you do and more than that the
way that you do it
um i just i appreciate it and uh
and you know it's it's you've been a
beacon
and a lighthouse uh to help guide my
direction
and i appreciate that so thanks man and
i should say
just in closing in the shameless plug
department the book is um
it's only available on my website we're
not selling it on amazon that's kind of
part of the whole self-publishing thing
so you could find it at ritual.com
and i will and we're offering signed
copies so if you want to sign copy
um copy it i signed like 750 the other
day it took me like five hours
like it is crazy but happy to do it so
you can learn more about the book and
all that kind of stuff there
yes go to richroll.com vc for voicing
change that's the direct url or you can
just go to richrold.com the book is
proudly
displayed there and that is amazing
to know that you'll sign and personalize
um thanks for you know
making sure that we can include that for
those i'll put it in the show notes and
please go get a copy it's stunning it i
again i watched it just
grab a hold of my wife and put her on
the couch for a while and inspire
the hell out of her uh thanks so much
for being on the show again everyone
check out rich's new book at ritual.com
vc answer a few questions in the
meantime
take care of yourself man grateful to
have you on the show and thank you for
inspiring me and so many others
thank you man much love thanks for
everybody who
who watch along really really appreciate
it thanks chase peace
you